okay for people joining this live stream
we are discussing a strange topic we are
discussing progress on progress
indicators okay so launched the
prototype build try these examples in a
terminal yeah you can try the well try
them here in the notebook just but then
also we you know it's worthwhile to try
them in the terminal what's happening
here okay things going very wrong
did we have any Wolfram backstab
prototype build oh that build is too old
okay I'll run a mathematical prototype
build hopefully that's newer know what
the heck's going on
I think if well the prototype build
switched over to being 12.2 once we
froze last week so okay so is Roger on
this Co like a costume too beautiful
yeah I'm here where is the wear of the
prototype though I didn't know that that
happened so I don't have them you don't
have 12 to prototype builds no okay all
right so somebody else will have to demo
this Giulio are you prepared to demo yes
[Music]
the one which we are using here okay so
okay that doesn't look good because it
says it's blue so what's going on there
oh this this is a right now it's a
context function okay father
it's doing whatever yes back to B so let
me maybe just say the we started this
from the job that Tolly did couple years
ago so we clarify some design issue
yesterday with Billy we are now using
the latest design assets the only thing
that we didn't really like about that
syntax was it was it has a very
convoluted way to specify what to
monitor so right now
yeah let's just do the demos first okay
maybe just actually like this is a
function this is a content you want to
monitor and then you just provide some
information so this is with zero delay
and you're providing an initial time
estimates that is using here okay so
design wise this isn't really quite
right
I mean we've we've got multiple what I
wanted to see was the various designs
that we have in different places in the
system you know some with bars going
across some without exactly but the
whole thing is here we are hiding the
whole complexity of the design behind
the content you specify so here you
never ask anything in this one here you
say oh I know how to monitor progress so
just the idea is that here you are
waiting one second and then you are
printing the progress bar okay and and
then you can have a sort of combinations
so you can have you know these with
automata this is remaining time this is
nice because I say automatic so
everything is estimated for you or you
can specify I don't know current by
count and this will just say the proper
bite thing and if you give where's that
light coming from how is it how is it
getting that bite count oh this is I
mean is you are just providing pointing
that to the variable yourself this
depends on the the function using the
progress indicator will have to provide
hooks for that so it'll be a callback
function of some kind of handler
function typically it will work like
monitor you have your function will say
to the progress indicator look at the
variable for example like dollar byte
count and then during the computation
you just set it to whatever you want and
this is dynamically updated I see right
so URL downloads to me it would have a
handler function that says the dollar
byte count right yeah right I mean
there's a question of you know do do we
want sort of you you know URL fetch or
whatever is the low-level function that
handles downloads to you know
automatically compute things and tie
into this but I guess that's assuming
well I think that there's an option
progress monitor error true or false
which you can set on automatic it will
do something potentially with a long
delay blah blah blah I mean the
low-level function could stick its neck
out and and say you know and say look at
me
if there's been long enough to lie this
is what we have implemented here with
shown so the idea is that now the export
cost a bunch of internal stop and
internal stuff at the lowest level like
first create a progress indicator when
for the pre-processing and when the
pre-processing is done this progress
indicator is replaced with another one
okay so this is all part of the export
video with ABI exactly hey this is nice
guys it's very nice
okay research data was already using
something that was basically very
similar to this just the different
syntax to call it that was the old
Kali's code and the entities now are not
using Oh
Internet cool okay this is my custom
build story has some internal issues but
top at the top there yes maybe one yeah
yeah no no I think that this oh yeah
this is basically what entity could do
you are you just specify this this is a
discussion open for day I guess like
okay what things you can specify and
then mix is like you keep whatever one
like total progress I presentation down
and this is just you know putting
everything together and GTG when I
launch a terminal kernel and and demo
one of these yes sure so for example you
want this and this is giving you the
dynamic updating in the the kernel here
or maybe you want something with a bar
magnificient and something maybe just I
hijack this because this has been
prepared today I guess if I can find it
yes so this is a way to tell the
progress indicator were to print itself
because you may want to replace an
existing
indicator so this way we have a loop of
it prints to inner indicators over each
other and then it goes back to the outer
indicator so this is basically how to
you know have nested function calls that
they don't pollute the space other in
that car in the terminal or in the
notebook I see so in other words as one
case that you might want is always paint
into the same progress indicator and not
really might one because the resource
system is already using this and then
the fact that the entity framework is
not using this causes the cell you know
to go away and reappear all the time
because you print it you clean up you
print it right so I think this Swiss
which must much nicer because though
there's a certain target and that the
default should be to have a signature
for what is generating the progress
indicator
always present in the progress
indicators so you can see that change
you see what I'm saying so in other
words if it like a you know it's it's
putting up a single progress indicator
box and then sometimes it's the box is
the responsibility of this thing
sometimes it's the responsibility of
that thing okay you want the name of the
runner basically that's what I'm
suggesting yes because that way that way
if for the user if a user adds one of
these then they could by default I think
the default behavior of a single
progress indicator is a good idea rather
than spawning lots of sub progress
indicators which then go away and I mean
it might be useful to see the thing as
you know a series of recursive progress
indicators so to speak but it might also
be if you a thing is like if you say
that you don't want the automatic
container you just want no container you
can this is the behavior when you just
print multiple of them I see so
automatic container just means you're
overwriting the same container exactly
so the old behavior was that here you
would put a variable that you take care
of printing yourself and you can still
do that
I just told that it would be nice for
the user not to be preoccupied with
creating a symbol printing it then I'm
gonna be then removing it I think that's
good
can you give like a name oh yeah yeah I
mean the the to do the old thing that
you had are you but every even if but
it's what if I wanted container goes to
you know a yes you can do this you do
prints temporary or right yeah I wasn't
I'm not even talking about that where
you're doing it yourself but I'm saying
if you if there's if you might have
multiple things remain are thing that
you want to print out a second indicator
but then you want the top one to
override itself sometimes you want if
you want more than just automatic and
and none if you want to have five
different names containers you know why
not why not just have just put it be
able to put an arbitrary name there and
then that name and what would happen is
it will put up
containers that it knows a you know it
throws everything into container three
if you say container three for
everything everything overwrites
container three but container one is
separate from container three without
using a variable yourself yeah without
using everything increase it it's it's
yeah right it's it's more like you know
so in reap being able to have a tag
right right so it's a container tag okay
I guess then those could be strings and
they will work like automatic but with
automatic yes exactly and if it's the
same string of the same integer the same
expression doesn't really matter you can
have anything that it's the same
expression I don't think it can be
anything right the symbols I mean the
case value it can be very weird yeah you
don't want yeah I don't think we need
that much freedom a string and a symbol
is probably enough it seems I mean I
don't think we want a symbol because
symbol there's a question visit the
evaluated value of the symbol that
affects the container destination or is
it the name of the symbol I think for
now why don't we just say that they have
to be literals integers or strings make
sense yeah the reason why I wanted the
symbol was just basically to save Bob
current case where he was taking care of
a printing himself like this he was
inking the container when it's gone when
it's a symbol what it does is it sets
that symbol to the progress and I think
that's a good behavior it's a limit
let's unpack that behavior but hold on a
second we also want container names that
are things like lists because I can
imagine a case where you having
recursive containers here what you do
want lists I mean imagine imagine the
case where you want your progress
indicator to be in a separate panel that
you've put in a notebook somewhere right
then having that symbol container is the
way to do it I'm not completely
understanding right you have some
dynamic GUI that's sitting somewhere
that's not I think you should have a
separate variable that represents the
you know basically contain a name it's
not it's something different I mean it's
something like it's the container
dynamic symbol which you can set that
binds this container to the value of
that dynamic symbol do you understand
what I'm saying if you let me explain
this let me explain different so let me
explain the container thing is something
that tells you where to paint this
progress indicator on the screen right
what visual dynamic module is something
to paint this into am i making sense yep
there's a separate thing which is to
take this whole progress indicator and
bind it to the dynamic value of a symbol
so that you can transport it and use it
somewhere else okay
so the idea that to recreate this we
would do container automatic gnome Bowl
XXX exactly exactly
that's what I'm saying it's partially
called contain a symbol but yeah um note
um right I think that's the way to do it
okay well this looks really nice
actually
okay so let's go to let's talk um okay a
question from our live stream from Brian
is the indicator outputting ansi escape
sequences in this one yes yeah so it's
well it's vt100 right oh it's lovely how
that does any who here knows what a
vt100 actually is I have actually I've
seen a vt100 connected via serial cable
to our to our ultrasparc server when I
was in college okay anybody else know
what a vt100 is no it's it's a physical
terminal CRT type terminal made by
Digital Equipment Corporation um it was
a modern terminal back in maybe 1980
one so um right so one of the things
we've not tested that and and you'll see
this under future directions is you know
what happens if we try this in different
terminals like on the windows you know
in a Windows console or parallel so
that's something that will write need a
lot of testing Ryan and I live stream is
asking what is more information here do
it does nothing
that's just it was just the the output
of the detail there oh yeah yeah I put
it here but you can have here the one
that gives you the byte count and right
but it's a pure read only thing it
doesn't on a pure terminal you can't
like put a hyperlink there's a yes but
this you know you can have something
that updates automatically so this is
this is a possible spin-off of this
project or like side project is do you
want to you know style the terminal the
question is how much can style will be
pushed in in a terminal which I think we
can do like old and some colors wow I
had no idea so I mean well the style
string thing I mean it would just be
style right being something that would
work in the terminal right so yeah but
the way to hook up don't tell me you can
put graphics on the terminal can unless
we want to like do ASCII art which we
did in version one let's know there's no
way care and every now and then we still
get complaints about the fact that STR
it doesn't work anymore and
[Music]
computational geometry meets ask y'all
if you can't determine the download time
you need to put in a shrug yeah okay
but seriously I have no idea what these
terminal I mean I assume that they don't
support some weird you know graphics
primitives type things yeah I there
there are some that will allow you to
insert images intermix images and text I
don't know how you test for that and we
can turn the trans cat and stick it in I
don't think there's anything that really
does vector graphics in the term home
okay but maybe there's something a term
cap file that indicates whether it's
possible to do that it would be nice
let's at least find that out what's that
it's possible it I'm sorry you're saying
it's not possible it's not possible
yes okay all right fine so you have to
summarize this right now this has eight
color implementation and 256 there's
fancier things that is supported by even
less yeah it's amusing it's amusing and
I think it I think it's a separate
branch just just mentioning is it not
really low hanging fruit but there's a
Hank yeah it's a it's fruit that's
available through different colored
fruits as well um okay okay so I've got
another question um in the progress
indicator do we imagine that there's a
kill button like an X yeah we have a
design here right now okay
maybe I should open was it in questions
yeah yeah yeah
so the idea behind our live stream is
saying that the the new windows console
does support ANSI and also that there
are graphics characters and ansi escape
sequences nice thanks oh okay let's find
out about that I mean it will be
entertaining to be able to actually
generate graphics out but particularly
since we are you know with Wolfman
engine use going up there are people who
are using Wolfram engine and you know 30
year old terminal type scenarios okay
so some question that we put together
yesterday okay the first one was this
peanut thing that you really discuss and
then the second one is already what you
asked for
so basically we have put together two
different kind of buttons that users
might might be interested in the first
one is basically abort
so that's right now those are two
different actions
exactly so is and there's a third action
which is get rid of the progress
indicator yes which may be the X and X
like this
nobody smell that's a very heavy hand
exactly this is a big one so I don't
know I mean you can always you can
always delete it like this yeah and and
I don't I'm not gonna press delete but
you can only it's a cell so you can you
can always do this and that's it not
come back I'm sorry what you always do
you just delete the cell yeah okay fair
enough
it's it's I know it's order 0
approximation but it's invisible okay so
having fancy graphics definitely has to
be possible I mean it definitely has to
be possible to take this framework and
put an arbitrary dynamic graphic in
there yeah I don't think we I mean I
don't really think this is let me take
something like text which is let's go to
a simple one I don't think that there's
anything that prevents that let's see it
might break horribly so okay well but is
it updation oh no because it's it's not
a rule delayed but entertaining it's
mean there there's no reason for that
not to work like that I guess the main
the main question is this stuff uses
something which is a let's say yeah
relative to let's see if we have
something preset yeah like this which is
relative to information data which is a
completely different design
let's talk about that information panel
yes
thank you die okay the question is
visual design wise how do these things
fit together and that's not good okay
who do we have from design here I'm Gary
hi I'm Billy
okay what do we do so I mean I'm quite
keen on the the the the design template
on the Left seems fine for these pure
progress indicators the question is how
do we go to I mean I think we have to I
don't think it's the right thing to have
an information panel based version of
the thing on the right I think we have
to have something more lightweight and I
think it should say something like net
train Progress dot dot or something and
then have this and I think we've got to
carry over this blue concept and thin
down this this thing at the top comments
from people right so I think I agree can
you actually evaluate a or are you in a
broken build and can't train anything
yeah you know it's been broken for a
while but I can just note my no
confession no just go back to a
production build yes let's go to an old
one okay okay so we
what happens dynamically let me
screenshot of this okay right so I think
yeah I was hoping Etienne would be here
so we could have a slightly more but you
know there is a way to get it to put the
screenshot in your clipboard I use it
all the time but is it command my
fingers no it Itamar on the control
shift for that's right oh thanks
let me type it for thanks so let's say
this is the one dynamic and this is a
static one at the end of it so at the
end yeah this is a typesetting of a
natural result object which is not the
progress indicator it just happened to
use the same function to display but why
isn't the net train result just a
classifier or something oh no because
they asked all is a specific output I
say this is if I want that I do this and
yeah I find net whatever and I get it
out okay okay okay the string curve is a
bug then there's there's some weird
format and go yeah that's some kind of
weird thing yeah no but I think that
this is an amine visit an old builder so
okay all right okay but I hadn't seen
the old output there so there's a way of
generating actual output from the thing
which is very similar to the progress
indicator it's like the end state of the
progress indicator yeah this is what all
the old classified information and
predictor information when returning I
think the this design was invented for
them right but so now that's what
information returns and it consistently
does so in a box of that type exactly
exactly they are not using the same
function but they personally I would be
happy to see those boxes in general slim
down that header at the top
let me just do it there you I think I
think things actually produced by
information is yes yeah I think that
should be slimmed down that that thing
that the top should be a smaller font
size and slimmed down
I mean try information of tungsten or
something the entity tungsten entity
yeah okay now hit and you don't need to
do that see I think that entity
superstructure is way too big I think
that should be at least two three points
smaller design folk any comments yeah I
think that's fine then is what's full
data set below it's matching the same
style but I don't know what that does
but that gets the whole thing that's a
yeah that's an active button it's not
very clear from no hover yeah weird I
think it should be so we can greater
than greater than yeah okay so there's
two things to fix here whose be aiming
okay so can you make sure that those
both of those things get get some
potential designs for slimmer heading
and better additional actions yes yes
okay okay okay so meanwhile I don't see
why we shouldn't have a blue for in
progress and a gray for finished and
have some consistency between those
boxes and if we say at the top of the
main box go go back to the progress box
that you screenshotted okay there okay
so I think we could perfectly well say
training in progress at the top in a in
a blue box you know with a blue blue
bordering blue top for the thing and
then give that give that same kind of
slider um
the okay so I think we can merge these
designs and have the panel at the bottom
be look just as it does here that make
sense to people when you say panel at
the bottom do you mean just the plots or
do you include the like progress time
that that table I think the progress in
time is fine I don't think that's a
hugely I mean the fact that that isn't
quite the same as it isn't the other
things doesn't seem horrendous to me but
that it stays in wider is a part of the
blue section I would say stay in white
because I think there's the possibility
of all kinds of complicated stuff there
okay it's very specific I mean one
possibility that just came to mind is
that this thing here could have a I mean
this function here that the computation
with progress could have a switch that
to go from like a kind of appearance
minimal which is this one and full
appearance were where each key that you
specify is expanded like this yeah it's
possible I think that might be overkill
but it's possible right so so Julie oh
gee do you know like these graphs are
they like hand sized and labeled or you
know do they just sort of specify a
couple of variables and something
automagically sizes everything for them
I do not think we are automatically
sized you I think you can specify what
things you want to monitor but other
than that I think they are automatically
sized I don't think you can controlled
the parameters of the right so so that
to me suggests that maybe what we need
is well that's not going to tell you
right I think is no but the point is two
things you can have training progress
measurements which is the option that
does this so if this one says two
InFocus measurement accuracy and it
prints this Wow I wasn't aware of
so yes that I mean okay so you have a
whole carousel of different things you
can print that right so I think what
we'll need is another key of like you
know monitored you know monitoring plots
or something panel why don't you just
call the whole thing a panel I mean it
is a panel mm-hmm and then you put
whatever you want in there but let's go
back to the basic designs here okay um
by the way Brian and I live stream is
asking whether the blue color could be
changeable I guess we could have it be
changeable why not a background color as
as part of the options here I think
that's useful because I think I could
imagine that you might want some kind of
you know bright warning thingy that
something is taking too long I'm making
sense then yeah I mean it could in
principle it could even take a base
style but I can just pass through
whatever it ya feel to the thing and
then you can use it to customize
whatever somebody's asking key Laplace
transforms of course you can go look in
the documentation no don't
okay all right let's let's go back here
okay can we look at the designs please
down below though which one no no that
the the graphic design oops your Afric
design okay so
I think my main question is how to deal
with stop abort and remove this display
box I'm not thrilled with the idea that
you get rid of it by deleting cell so my
question really is how about the
following possibility how about when you
mouse over this thing you get some kind
of menu not necessarily mousing at well
you could when you mouse over that I
mean I think the general thing you don't
really want to gum it up with aborting I
mean especially not you know if you want
to have an abort thing come up you don't
want to have an abort thing come up in
two seconds if the things been there for
a minute then ah you know then that
becomes reasonable right I'm not making
sense but you don't want an in two
seconds a big thing that says abort to
come up so one possibility is when you
mouse up to give an indicator with an ax
of some kind that you could stop things
or something or there's a way to stop
stuff and have that have when you mouse
over well probably the whole box but you
would might target that X then it comes
up with a menu that allows you to do
different things
am I making sense yes so we definitely
need to add an option to the function
which is what to do when well if it has
it I mean look it may be that the only
thing you can do is abort yeah exactly
so I mean the color or the person using
the progress indicator can always I mean
the default is that you just abort it of
course but if you
we need to induce an option to the
progress indicator or you say what you
want to do when you cancel instead of
aborting well I'm
I'm not sure I agree with this I mean I
think right I mean I think we should
distinguish between the things that
always make sense and the things that
only sometimes make sense right so if we
have a little you know a little X button
which always provides two options delete
this progress indicator and abort
computation that's great but I think
like the stop button should be its own
distinct button that only sometimes
appears that's a very different action
and only sometimes I don't it requires
quite fancy footwork to be able to
support a stop button right but most
things will not support it exactly yeah
this is up to daily up to the function
with your monitoring well I mean an
example of one entity prefetch would
support it because it doesn't really
matter how much you prefetch although
abort and stop are more or less the same
thing in that case I mean net rain
already it supports it I understand that
I understand that that's the only case I
know of that supports it right and right
and sort of you know a general import or
I mean there are some formats where you
can import fractionally but right you
can't import half of a JPEG okay all
right okay
we understand look the most common case
the fact that there is an abort here is
merely a convenience because everybody
you know who uses the system
substantially knows you would type come
on period to abort but this is a and and
by the way the question would be does it
abort the whole computation or is it
just to bought this particular part of
it I think it should realistically I
bought the whole computation because
there's no guarantee this thing's gonna
clean up after itself that's only when
you have a stop button
well so I also don't think that you know
there might be a big computation people
might want to have some protection on
aborting the thing okay what's this this
can be an optional actually because
right now it propagates the abort you
could specify with an option that you
don't want to propagate the abort okay
okay if you download I don't know
whether you've got this in the inventory
but when you launch parallel kernels
there's some weird antiquated dialog box
that I'm not dialog temporary yes I
don't want to demo I want a screenshot
of all the weird things we have yeah
this yeah right and I this was one of
the things that I try to do a big in the
beginning to try to hook it up there
okay I understand I understand but what
I want to see is screenshots of all of
the different cases of progress
indicators well we have its where is it
is in the judo ticket can I can you
bring it up please
yes sure do you remember
yeah it's LCC 167 okay and is the one
you yeah okay so this not
is our let me see it let me see them all
our shows everything oh boy there are a
lot yes no no I just
just open every cell okay let's scroll
through the screen shots I don't
remember the thingy but oh I have to
select everything here okay okay okay
just scroll through it all right so
we've got those grey bars we've got that
weird thing
okay scroll down this looks like a
useful piece of work here was this
Devin's work collecting all the stuff it
was that first session and then I'd
added periodically to it okay okay wait
wait wait wait wait stop stop
so that's another case right there's a
loading indicator with a with a spinner
like that yeah oh and also in here we
have the same thing I thought we we deem
that these were like two tangents that
will be covered by the first that's fine
that's fine but I just want to know what
they all are yeah and for example you
know if we're gonna go with blue we
might want to use some kind of bluish
tint for those spinners right and I mean
the font okay go ahead search index okay
scroll Scroll scroll Scroll scroll we've
seen all those okay web search but back
back back up back up so that was another
crazy one which was totally there yet
right this is an old one okay just using
the progress bar okay system model areas
complete independent well it needs to be
it needs to have the same you know needs
to it and why well that's not completely
true right because it's not well this is
another thing we were supposed to have a
meeting about is these end product
browsers I'm making sense can we make
sure that gets scheduled please yes yeah
I'll bring it up with Bradley okay all
right keep going
I mean there's those things there those
dots are the exact equivalents of the
spinners being used elsewhere right so
we need to decide which it is we're
using all we need to decide that and
when there's one of it we use dots and
when they're multiple things we use
spinners or something but this has to be
some consistency makes sense mm-hmm yep
okay keep scrolling oh boy something
completely different and crazy right so
that's a system model of thing which
needs to be standardized with our other
progress stuff I think this looks like
the net train it just they think it's a
Linux shot or something I see okay I
think some some us it's yes some us it's
our okay keep scrolling down please okay
all right good all right let's go back
to your agenda here okay all right so
right so I mean one of the obvious next
steps is you know once you've sort of
signed off on on this general design is
you know getting all the you know the
things that more or less used this type
of progress indicator to use our new
function and that you examine both
things yep okay I should it be a system
function yes it should be and I think
what do we have we have progress monitor
is an option is it not for certain
things can you look at that please
progress indicator no this is the this
is this training course monitor I think
is option film that I know sometimes
yeah yeah this stream progress reporting
no on that right now takes panel print
progress indicator or whatever okay
so going back to the progress indicator
itself that should probably be restyled
that the actual thing called progress
indicated in the UI that should probably
modernized and restyle to align with
whatever we're doing here you mean this
yes I mean that right well I know I mean
that that is that is sort of directly
tying into right that's a representation
of a standard UI Ellen I am the standard
I understand it I'm just saying I don't
know if it's modern version of that
element hands on the OS I don't really
know it's using the OS element are you
sure I'm pretty sure I don't I think we
let's check that put it on the shelf we
need to check that okay okay so let's go
back over to the left here try to get
Lou okay um so what this is gonna have
to say I mean you know what the system
level function progress monitored or
something like that
um um could it could whoever's
monitoring this live stream somebody is
asking questions like is this software
only on the web could somebody else
answer those questions please we don't
need to see those that's not relevant to
this okay
okay
so here let's see if we have something
like progress monitored to go back up to
your function at the top yeah so I mean
we're going to have the thing you're
monitoring and then we're going to have
a whole bunch of we're gonna have
probably an association worth of gunk
about what you're doing right I don't
understand why that why that's broken
into several pieces there with I mean I
would have thought we should just have
everything in one big association
including the time delay is there or you
have a different idea yeah I had the
debate when he died about this I think
he agrees with you I'm not so convinced
the point is that these stuff here is
options to the function to the progress
indicator function these represent the
content of what you're printing I think
there are conceptually different things
there are conceptually a little death
well they might be different yes I agree
that those are things the the outer
things are things that are fixed for
this for every instance of this progress
monitor yeah you're not you're not gonna
have delay key or update the delay
because either you print it or not print
it after two seconds so or background or
things like that I mean you you might
want to change the background
dynamically yes but and I I'm I'm not
particularly fond of any of the two I'm
not really fond of the syntax of this
but we focus on punctuality first and
and then we think a bit about how to
package this
um okay I mean I have to go in a moment
here but but I before you go I think
what happens when you wrap one of these
in in Priya's protect so the content
here
no no wrap transfer touch around that
whole shell around the cross
this is blocking the dynamic coalition
make sure nothing trouble happens I mean
that whole I mean the whole control
equals hanging thread female third we
had recently revolved around one of the
issues in this was the behavior so whose
dynamic de Junio changed at 25 - like I
know a hundred or something so we
actually well maybe not quite that long
and maybe do one where you actually
monitor the variable rather than doing
the automatic okay so like here let's
say hundred here and it says i korean
protect okay all right so I guess here
we'll never see it because there was oh
yeah maybe the delay makes it never fire
but yeah so here the problem should
never actually update so what's
different I mean well first of all that
make sure doesn't break does this woman
terrible like hang but we also I mean
maybe we need to come up with a
different behavior if you're running
frantically yes we do have a way to do
that no yeah and we just don't bring it
up if you're running preemptively I mean
it's not gonna be able to do anything
useful you could just print something
that doesn't look like it's supposed to
update yeah I don't yeah yeah why would
you just say something or other dot dot
dot yeah we I mean I have a default text
for when you don't give anything the
this is saying like oh yeah I broke it
down with an update but they say my
cooperation in progress dot dot dot and
that can contain only you can just be
you know a string you just say computing
dot dot it's always computing it's a
computer yeah and we could have we could
you I mean in a notebook right
we could use of an Fe only dynamic thing
right like like the necklace yeah I mean
my idea was to have something like like
this well you have your computing here
and then something like progress
indicator I think how is called ellipses
[Music]
nope
is lips I asked yep
so this could be the content you know
why not and I guess we can probably just
directly do it here to see how it would
look like yeah so this this would be
beautiful whatever you and I committed
fault the fault if you actually
specified nothing else yeah yeah yeah
although I think the thing needs some
kind of tag for what this I mean again
you cannot specify it but generally I
think it needs some origin tag because
otherwise things can be you know
downloading one thing is just notice in
the design was this it was implemented
in terrace version i think this was one
of the possibilities what what if we
like it something you see very to tip
oh so this could give acceleration over
we could just print it inside if we have
something appellate relief
fuel-efficient probably the only
question now we shouldn't give the head
because that could be very obscure I
have never noticed that tooltip oh no no
isn't is nowhere
it's just that only this this is a
design templates um okay I unfortunately
have to go this this is this is good but
it's gonna need one more iteration of
you know detailed design of the actual
list of things that are supported inside
this whatever this is going to be called
progress monitor or something
duh progress monitored whatever I mean
it has to be it's a little different
from monitor and it also relates to the
whole thing about monitored map and so
on
I'm got two comments on the livestream
one is apparently the windows console
that supports ASCII escape sequences is
in public beta doesn't and so one
question that I would have there is if
you generate those escape sequences in a
version in the terminal that does not
support them does the term cap mechanism
just eat them or does it produce does it
print garbage on the screen prints for
the question yeah if you do that it will
print garbage on the screen
the country read etcetera term cap and
find out whether you can do it exactly
thank you for your question yes this was
the first issue that we noticed and so
if it for example the idea is like the
our our notebook doesn't work with that
so if I look here what are you talking
about the that we're talking about the
ASCII version yeah exactly
so if I do notebooks phos this will you
know I just tell it I'm not even
notebook and you see here you don't see
any any escape sequence because I'm
checking I'm not in the terminal but
suppose it and what is the term cap for
our terminal it's an interesting
question which hasn't been noticed in 30
years you know like there isn't one
right this is just printing strings one
after each other fair enough okay
also on live stream point being made be
nice if progress bars had a pause button
that is an interesting idea what I would
do yeah we're good would agree it would
take longer to get the answer Yeah right
you kept running out I suppose it in
interface to the well the only issue no
the only thing I can imagine is if it's
printing some nice plots like the
what's that like you're on that training
what I could imagine is oh I want to
screen capture that plot you see what
I'm saying okay both opposed that's is
that kind of a disable updating of the
interface it's like no no no no no no no
I mean as you're seeing it it's like oh
that's an interesting configuration let
me screen capture that okay so you want
a button to screen to screen cup the
progress no no no no I want something
where if there is something going on in
the progress indicator that you want to
see for example the screen capture it or
whatever or just to write down the
answers or to copy out the answers that
would be the case where I could imagine
a pause will be useful yeah you may want
to pause the process itself as well I'll
give you an example I'll give you an
example if it's scanning over lots of
files and doing something on them you
might say oh I wonder if this is the
right thing before I just do this to a
thousand files let me go check something
yeah we're printing something anytime
there's a side effect it's happening you
might want to pause that side effect
putting a pause the computation and then
look if we end up with a menu for what
the actions are we should consider pause
which we could implement quite easily
because we're just changing um ok and
there was another comment I'd be helpful
to have an option to leave the progress
bar in place rather than disappearing
well yeah I mean the question is at the
end is that at a print temporary which
disappears when the progress is finished
kind of think if you want it to stay use
echo
I mean the point is that by default
definitely we don't want it because we
are now particles that can you know
obviously not right you can you can do
it right now
if you use that other syntax of printing
the the whole container business where
you print the I see I see what you're
saying you swing it yourself so instead
of printing it can be a trimmed and
that's all right I think one suggestion
that here in your notebook when you say
random image and it just really at that
there could be a release of images you
just play circularly for jumper you only
want to just play clock or something
yeah so instead you may provide your own
images just play note without computing
them oh yeah I mean you can put a little
function you want here you can put a
function that every time you people read
it I mean this stuff here respects
actually I didn't put it here but with
respects the update interval which is
also system symbol I guess yes so if I
do update interval one this will update
every second and everything every
dynamic element in the progress
indicator respects this so if you put
your own function to generate something
here it will be cold
you know you guarantee that it will be
called every one second and it will do
whatever you want it to do okay so you
can be fancy if you if you don't can use
this I which your monitor oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean I can do in here if I put I
in this will just be I yeah that's right
yeah this scenario about posing answer
whoever she actually oh yeah I sent you
an email with some a rough design with
the buttons okay I'll just bring it up
you send it to my personal email okay
here it is okay
just double-click so you can get that
full screen so Iman yeah I don't
remember how you do that just
double-click it I mean you know if you
double-click it okay on it and then just
go full screen clicking the image just
open it yeah oh yeah isn't by the it's a
with email client let's let's forget it
you
mmm it's getting there but isn't quite
right I think yeah um I think it looks a
heck a lot better with the smaller
heading for that training progress thing
um and you're not going blue why are you
not going blue in the thing on the right
well I was trying to show what it would
look like in white since we've already
done it in blue I know there was a
request in the live stream to be able to
change the coloring so I just wanted to
maybe show you know I think we want blue
tiles I hope we want a blue we want that
to indicate it's sort of an out-of-band
thing that's happening um
I don't think that that well the idea of
savaging the slider you know the
progress indicator with all that stuff
at the top I mean I suppose that's
possible with a suggestion that there'd
be this way of opening out the
Association to display it in that form
rather than having it be an inline thing
alright this needs more more work um is
getting there let's maybe in a week or
so we can pick this up again there's
really good progress the so progress
indicator bracket I have to go I have to
go so you guys can continue but I've got
to go um is that using the OS progress
indicator always are just some of the
time
it uses the the OS unless you set an
appearance it uses the built-in OS
version as you know as piped through our
front end okay so but also isn't some
don't aren't some of the appearance is
also using the OS appearances that
change the size would use the OS
appearances for things like necklace and
these things are all completely custom
okay alright okay question from here
okay well then let's wrap here okay
thank you run